lady gaga apologizes for working with  our Kelly following the release of  lifetime's docu-series surviving art  Kelly Gaga released a lengthy statement  on Twitter Wednesday night that read in  part quote I stand behind these women  1,000% believe them no they are  suffering and in pain  Gaga also called the allegations against  our Kelly horrifying and indefensible  the pair collaborated in 2013 on the  song do what you want the second single  off Gaga's album artpop since then Gaga  has come forward as a victim of sexual  assault which she mentioned in her  statement she explained quote I made  both the song and video at a dark time  in my life if I could go back and have a  talk with my younger self I tell her to  go through the therapy I have since then  so that I could understand the confused  post-traumatic state that I was in  moving forward Gaga said she intends to  have the song removed from iTunes and  streaming platforms and vowed to never  work with our Kelly again